es sind 600 Millionen Vögel weniger die
sind einfach weg selbst Story Leute
unseren Vögeln geht's richtig dreckig
aber hier kommen drei Sachen die
wirklich jeder machen kann und die den
Vögeln richtig helfen zum Beispiel
Wasser trinken aufstellen am besten
katzensichere wie hier auf so einem Stab
dann finden die auch viel zu wenig
Nistgelegenheiten also hängt so
möglichst hoch dass die auch Katzen
sicher sind möglichst viele Nistkästen
auf die am besten auch verschieden große
Öffnungen haben für die
unterschiedlichen Vogelarten und dann
haben die natürlich auch Hunger wenn ihr
Meisenknödel verwendet dann packt die
aus dem Netzen aus weil die Vögel sich
da drin verfangen können und macht die
lieber in so einem Behälter wie hier das
natürlich auch aufhängen oder so
aufbauen dass die Katzen nicht dran
kommen vielleicht auch auf den Stab und
dann denkt dran das Vögel auch
Krankheiten übertragen können wenn sie
in einem Vogelhaus fressen wo sie immer
auf das Futter drauf kacken deswegen
lieber so einen Futterbehälter hier
verwenden wo die Vögel außen sitzen und
nicht auf das Futter drauf kacken können
und den dann auch schön hoch auf